what's your sign
when's your birthday
i'm a toy i knew we were gonna get there
one i'm very close to toys
um i am i look at her she's like i can't
believe we're going to zodiac over are
you i'm going there you just met him i'm
just i want to know i'm um
cancer sun sign
scorpio rising okay and sagittarius moon
that's a good mix it's a great mix yeah
i'm happy yeah i would have said if it
wasn't um
no cancer well the cancer gives me that
sensitivity that you need to
add to scorpio gives you the fire and
scorpio gives you the fun yeah and then
the sagittarius gives you that wisdom
that says you know willing to teach
everybody yeah they're usually very
balanced yeah my mother was an
astrologist when i was a kid oh really
so i grew up with
food on the table because she was doing
people's charts oh wow what an
interesting household yours was beyond
kelly yeah my household was sounds like
camp no it was it's like nothing else
it's like a whole new experiment i grew
up in artists housing that's so cool in
manhattan that was the first one wow if
you made more than ten thousand dollars
a year you were kicked out of the
building but i'm just saying it's so
cool as in like the creativity that must
have been flowing john coltrane recorded
there miles davis recorded that every
it's
early hip hop record it was kiss
recorded in the building
in that building
that's awesome it's awesome
[Music]